so I was in the pro wrestling circuit
across the UK and Europe for about
probably in total like just over 10
years during my studies all the way
through my earlier recruitment career
and when I got The Apprentice audition I
had already had options to try out for
what is now the WWE the world wrestle
entertainment if you got the gig back
then it was 300 Days on the Road
throughout the world I'd never have time
for a life and a wife and all those
things so I actually think it really
really helped me with the auditioning
and getting on the apprentice and it's
helped me in life but that part of me
that gave me a character and like a
larger than life personality and I was
able to use elements like being
comfortable with wrestling in front of
several thousand people like in pair of
pants basically so if you can do that
you can talk to a bunch of business
experts on some as far as I'm concerned